إن مجسات شكل مختلف من
الحرب
تتغلغل في المجتمع العراقي ،
والكثير منهم معرضون للإصابة عندما تكون فرحة
السعادة تتلاشى رؤية المستقبل ،
ويقول المسؤولون إن شبكات المخدرات هنا
قد أصبحت أكثر تعقيدًا على مدى السنوات
القليلة الماضية
، وفي الآونة الأخيرة تجنيد المزيد  النساء
ثريا زوجها والرجل الذي تشير
إليه على أنه صديقهم
المهرّب باع واستخدم الكريستال ميث ،
فإن الصديق سيحصل عليه من الحدود الإيرانية
من التجار الكبار الذين
تقول إنهم استخدموها في الغالب
لتهريب مخزون المخدرات الخاص بهم عبر
نقاط التفتيش لأنها كانت تختبئ فقط
تحت ملابسها
وتميل النساء هنا إلى عدم التفتيش ،
فقد تم القبض عليهن جميعًا في منزل
كانوا يبيعون منه مع ما يقرب من 18000
من الكريستال ميث
[موسيقى]
وحدة مكافحة المخدرات في العراق التي
يقول المسؤولون إنها تعاني من نقص في الموارد البشرية وتمويلها
جعل
ما يعتبرونه إفلاسًا كبيرًا ،
كانت أكبر مضبوطاتهم في
جنوب البلاد بالقرب من الحدود مع
إيران
، نقطة العبور الرئيسية.  أو الكريستال
ميث عصر covet 19 نتج عنه
زيادة في الطلب
اللواء أحمد حسين من وحدة مكافحة المخدرات
يخبرنا
المزيد من البطالة ، المزيد من الشباب المحبط
المتسكع في الشوارع ،
المزيد من الأهداف سوف يمنح تجار المخدرات
شخصًا أو
اثنين مجانًا بشكل عام  يشرح حسين أنه
بمجرد أن يتم
إدمانهم ، يبدأون في كثير من الأحيان في التعامل مع أنفسهم لتمويل إدمانهم الخاص
، ولدى الوحدة معلومات تفيد بأن التجار
ينشطون في هذا السوق ،
ويتحدث الجنرال حسين مع أشخاص
يمنحهم رقم الخط الساخن للحصول على النصائح
التي يحصلون عليها بالمئات يوميًا ويحاول
تخفيف البعض الآخر.  من المحنة القائمة
بين السكان وقوات الأمن ،
فهو يقارن تجارة المخدرات المزدهرة
بوجه آخر للإرهاب
[موسيقى]
لقد انتهى عصر الحرب التقليدية مع جيشين في مواجهة بعضهما البعض. يقول إن
أعداء العراق يتعاطون المخدرات أيضًا من
أجل  تدمير قلب
مجتمعنا شبابنا
سجن دائرة مكافحة المخدرات في
بغداد الغربية
ممتلئ ، كل زنزانة من المفترض أن تستوعب 30
ولكن هناك أكثر من 50 رجلاً هنا من
التجار
والمدمنين حتى عام 2016 ، يقول خالد أنه كان لديه
عمل ثابت كمقاول أمني ،
ثم انهار كل شيء ، فقد فقد وظيفته
وتفاقمت حالة الاكتئاب.
وجه على الكاميرا يقول
إنه انتهى به الأمر بالسرقة من والدته المسنة
لتمويل عاداته الكريستالية الميثامفيتامين
هنا ،
كل نداء قادم على
صفحة فيسبوك إنز هو شخص آخر
تأمل أن تتمكن من المساعدة في علاج
مدمن مخدرات آخر يمكنها إبعاده عن
السجن.
رسالة من مراهق
في البصرة كتب أنه
يبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا
أنه يريد العلاج أنه يريد أن
يتحسن لكنه لا يعرف ماذا
يفعل
فينا مدرس الأحياء في المدرسة الإعدادية
الذي أدرك أن بعض طلابها
كانوا
يستخدمون يحاول  لرفع مستوى الوعي حول
الخيارات المتاحة للمدمنين
، يخشى العديد من المستخدمين الذين يرغبون في التعافي من
أن السلطات ستحتجزهم فقط ،
ما لا يعرفه معظمهم هو
أنهم إذا ذهبوا عن طيب خاطر إلى  إيهاب
لا توجد تداعيات قانونية بموجب
القانون العراقي
أم
[موسيقى
] الأسرة في مركز إعادة التأهيل هذا
مليئة بالأطباء هنا يخبروننا أنه يتعين عليهم
إخراج المرضى بشكل أسرع
مما يرغبون في
هذا الشاب الذي يقول إنه اعتاد قيادة سيارة
توك توك
عرض عليه أحد ركاب
الميثامفيتامين الكريستالي وكان ذلك
مدمن مخدرات
وجده والديه يحمل مسدسًا إلى رأسه
لأنه كان يعاني من هلوسات
أن الناس كانوا يأتون
إليه ويأمرونه بقتل نفسه
[موسيقى]
تم إخراج أحمد من المستشفى يومين  قبل ذلك ، لكنه
يقول
إنه لا يزال لديه الرغبة الشديدة في
إعادته إلى جنوب العراق ، وتخشى والدته من إعادته إلى منزله في جنوب
العراق.
قامت بتقييد شبابها مرارًا
وتكرارًا وتخاطر الآن بفقدان المزيد منها بسبب
الإدمان
المدعومة من أروى ديمون سيينا